president Trump's pick to fill the
vacancy on the Supreme Court will face
his critics and supporters in a
confirmation hearing tomorrow Fox News
chief legal correspondent and anchor of
Fox News Tonight shannon bream looks at
some of the big issues for the high
court this fall a judge must be
independent must keep an open mind in
every case it is a promise every nominee
to the Supreme Court makes an ideal that
inevitably runs into partisan pushback
we have a lot of issues about
presidential power because he has
weighed in on these issues has a
profound burden to show that he will
serve as a fair and independent check on
the president tonight Trump introduced
Cavanaugh a progressive groups rallied
at the Supreme Court and sounded the
alarm
[Applause]
beyond that the Supreme Court in coming
months may confront other divisive
issues whether a forty-foot Latin cross
honoring World War one veteran's
violates the prohibition of government
endorsement of religion whether bans on
plastic guns made from a 3d printer
violate the Second Amendment state
regulations on surrogate pregnancy and
for Medicaid funds used for abortion and
the limits of executive power in ongoing
challenges to president Trump's
immigration environmental and regulatory
policies the Supreme Court in the last
few years has really become the decision
maker of last resort on so many issues
that have polarized our society judge
Kavanagh a decade ago suggested
providing sitting presidents with a
temporary deferral of civil and criminal
prosecutions it really makes sense to
make sure as a country that we give our
president as much room as possible to
operate free from the usual burdens of
the citizen citizen that has many
Democrats worried Kavanagh would protect
the man who nominated him from any
Muller probe subpoena judge Cavanaugh
his judicial philosophy incorporates an
almost minar kacal view of executive
power and accountability animated by a
belief that our chief executive gets to
play by a different set of rules while
working for independent counsel Kenneth
Starr Cavanaugh advocated an aggressive
approach to get President Clinton to
detail under oath the extent of his
relationship with intern Monica Lewinsky
the man who recruited Cavanaugh now
admits the judge's views may have
evolved on how far the current special
counsel regulations can be applied what
do you suggest is Congress take a look
at this and consider whether to
essentially have a postponement or a
timeout
it's a perfectly reasonable position but
he's speaking as a thoughtful observer
and not as a judge Republicans say the
judge's views are being distorted and
that his record has earned bipartisan
praise supporters note Cavanaugh has not
voted in any election since becoming a
judge to take himself at least in his
own mind away from the political process
and just be a neutral nonpartisan judge
my
Shannon thanks very much